i don't want to spend christmas in the
kitchen ignoring my family and friends
when we're all finally together so i'm
prepared with dishes that i can cook in
advance that will last over christmas
adding a glazed ham to your holiday menu
is a great way to get ahead it's
delicious versatile and the ultimate
dish to have in the fridge for any
hungry guests who drop by
christmas would not be the same without
a beautiful delicious honey glazed ham
across that long christmas period this
can get you out of jail quite easily ham
salads ham sandwiches ham egg and chips
this is a gammon what you do now is cook
it so it becomes a ham
into a pan
first things first the water
cover it completely so the whole
gammon cooks evenly
the important part now
is adding flavor in there
carrots in
the leeks
the more veg in there now the more
fragrant the broth becomes
once the ham is cooked that stock is
extraordinary
the base to a fantastic soup onion not
finely chopped
and then
homemade ham stock is packed with flavor
so it's great for making soups sauces
stews and risottos plus it can be frozen
so it's there when you need it
pan down
[Music]
peppercorns
lightly crush then to give it a
christmas flavor i'm adding crushed
coriander seeds
two cinnamon sticks
and four aromatic bay leaves up to the
boil and then turn it down let it simmer
and then skim it
cooking a ham isn't hard but it does
take time
this two kilo joint takes two and a half
hours to simmer before it's glazed and
baked however it is worth it because it
tastes absolutely delicious
so the glaze
very very simple
demerara sugar
madeira
that sweetens the delays basically a
fortified wine couple tablespoons
in
and then
cherry vinegar again couple tablespoons
honey in
nice
bring that out to the ball
the longer you leave it on the stove the
darker it becomes you want your hand
really nice and dark then cook out the
glaze for three four minutes that
i'm happy with
lovely
[Music]
right the gammon's cooked now onto the
plate
carefully snip the string
nice and gently
peel back
get rid of the skin then crisscross it
don't push too deep
let the knife do the work
stud it
with some clothes
[Music]
look at it almost looks like an albino
pineapple the blaze
and just carefully
cover
start in the middle and let it work
round
oh
god
gently gently gently gently
it's not even roasted yet and it looks
amazing beautiful
look at that
half the delays over now into the oven
15 minutes
[Music]
it started to colour
get the rest of the delays
and pour that over
look at it wow
the more effort
passion
and love you show the ham now
the results are tenfold
look at it
every five minutes out of the oven
and glaze again
now back into the oven now
at 190 degrees
we're gonna baste
and roast for 35 minutes
delicious
next i'm going to make a pear and
saffron chutney this is a fruity relish
that works brilliantly with a sweet
aromatic ham
first things first slice the onion
fry the chopped onion in olive oil
without coloring it the important part
about this stage is the fact that we're
gonna layer the chutney with textures
from onion to apple to pear
and a nice little block of ginger
grating the ginger so the ginger sort of
disappears with the onions
then add the spices
a good grating of nutmeg
followed by a teaspoon of cinnamon
and a teaspoon of cayenne pepper to give
it a kick delicious i recently spent a
lot of time in india where chutneys
originated and discovered that whereas
british style chutneys tend to be cooked
and are usually quite sweet indian ones
are normally fresh spicier and quite
sour
next
demo sugar
[Music]
once that sugar is dissolved the white
wine vinegar all in
that's going to give this really nice
sort of sweet and sour flavor
from there our fruit
these are williams pears
pear
is the star of the chutney so keep it
quite rustic
next add chopped cooking apples their
tartness gives a lovely contrast of the
sweetness of the pears
to give it great texture
a handful of sultanas
pinch of saffron this gives it a really
nice depth a rich golden color
saffron is the world's most expensive
spice it's made from the dried stigmas
of the saffron crocus flower and as a
general rule of thumb the deeper the
colour of the threads the better the
quality
and to make it lighter the zest and
juice of two oranges
the orange and the saffron go really
well together
just squeeze that in there
this chutney is brilliant with ham
fantastic in salads
but equally as delicious
with fish whether it's a roasted cod
a grilled fillet of mackerel it goes
brilliantly well bring that up to the
ball
cook that out for 15 minutes
now tomatoes going at the end
and that brings a certain amount of
freshness to the chutney really helps to
give that nice texture
[Music]
mix that in
and literally cook it out for 30 seconds
[Music]
what's great about this chutney is that
as it matures its flavor gets better and
better and it will keep for up to six
months
fill up the jar
and that
is going to deliver
amazing flavor across christmas
[Music]
and look
my goodness me
that
is fit for a king
[Music]
[Music]
my new version of beef wellington
retains the luxuriousness which made it
brilliant in the first place but gives
it a seasonal lift
if you want to really spoil your friends
this christmas this is the perfect
special occasion dish
beef wellington has to be the ultimate
indulgence one of my all-time favorite
main courses and it would definitely be
on my last supper menu my version is a
lot lighter and sexier and for christmas
i'm gonna give it an added twist
first off the fillet of beef
now look at it it's beautiful
first the most important part is to sear
it salt pepper the fillet is the leanest
and the most expensive cut of beef it
comes from underneath the lower backbone
a part of the animal which has very
little muscle and this is what makes it
such a tender cut very very hot pan
olive oil and literally roll it around
the pan
we're not cooking the beef we're just
searing it which will really help
to give another layer of flavor and beef
in
lovely now use the side of the pan so
the beef
sears down the back when you tilt it
it's a secret to get it done quickly it
gives that really nice roasted flavour
delicious once you've got the colour
very carefully lift up the beef
and see it on top
and sear it on the bottom
out
and onto the plate
english mustard
what this does now
it gives it a bit of sort of bit of heat
just lightly brush
the mustard
over the beef
so really important that you do this
as the beef comes straight out of the
pan as the beef starts to cool down it
absorbs all that heat from the mustard
horseradish is a really nice alternative
as well just leave that to sit
and relax as the fillet rests prepare
the filling which is called a duck sale
put 700 grams of chestnut mushrooms into
a blender
add a chopped clove of garlic
season with salt and pepper
and blitz
[Music]
christmas wouldn't be christmas without
chestnuts i just crumble them in
to the mushrooms
the chestnut's sweet nutty flavour works
brilliantly with the earthy taste of the
mushrooms and because they contain more
starch and less oil than other nuts they
have a much softer texture that is
perfect for the filling
that smells amazing
smells like christmas
once the mixture is finely chopped cook
in a hot dry pan this removes the water
from the mushrooms and intensifies the
flavour
[Music]
you can see the water coming out
instantly
such an essential stage really critical
to the success of the wellington that
you dry those mushrooms out and get rid
of all that water take the mushrooms up
even further some fresh thyme in there
which will make it really nice and light
and fragrant when all the water's been
fried off remove from the pan and leave
to cool
then start assembling the wellington
stage one
wrapping the beef fillet first of all
these wonderful slices
of parma ham and look
beautiful
overlap it
and set it there
so the secret of overlapping the palmer
ham
is to make sure
it contains all those juices
coming out of the beef
in the traditional recipe for beef
wellington a thick chive and spring
onion pancake is used instead of ham but
the parmesan makes the dish much lighter
and its sweet salty flavor really
complements the mushroom and chestnut
filling
a little touch of pepper no salt because
the ham is naturally salty just a little
twist
of pepper
and then from there your mushrooms
and basically
mushrooms go on
use the back of the spoon to spread them
nice and thinly
half an inch from the ends
rump holes
no pop it
every time there's meat
now he comes
next lay the beef
on top
and very carefully
fold that over
now
we're going to lift that up
and wrap
the beef
nice and carefully so all that mushroom
and parmesan
is encasing the beef all the way over
push it nice and tight
roll it nice and tight
and go all the way over
now
the secret from here
is to really let the clint film do the
work just nip it at the ends
and squeeze
and what we're doing is just creating
this wonderful sort of cylinder shape
off
and then just twist it
nice and tightly
and the tighter is the more perfect the
shape
then place in the fridge for 15 minutes
to firm up
[Music]
once it's set it's ready for the final
wrap a little bit of tim film
puff pastry
beef
now
very carefully
first roll the puff pastry over the beef
until the two edges meet
then trim off any excess pastry
and twist the ends together to ensure
the beef is completely sealed in its
pastry case
to set that perfectly
and get it really nice and firm to make
it really cylinder tight
clip them over
[Music]
and just pull that nice and tight
but the big secret behind this is that
it can be done the night before and the
tighter the clint film the better the
shape
the more even the shape
the more even it cooks
put it back in the fridge for five
minutes to fill up again then take off
the climb film
always like the perfect christmas
cracker
to give the pastry a lovely rich golden
brown color when it bakes brush it with
egg yolk
and then finally you don't have to do
this but it's a chefy thing a little bit
decoration
back of the knife down
and then just twist
and mark the pastry when it comes out
the oven
it's got that wow factor
[Music]
add a generous sprinkle of salt to
ensure the pastry becomes lovely and
crisp then bake in an oven at 200
degrees for around 35 minutes depending
on how rare you like your beef once out
of the oven it's crucial you let the
wellington rest for at least 10 minutes
this allows the meat to relax and
reabsorb its delicious juices making
sure it's tender and succulent nice and
gently
hear that pastry how crisp that is this
is the bit
we've been waiting for
oh wow
my god
i'm in heaven and for me
if you want a really nice change to
roast turkey
this
has to be the ultimate for the table it
smells christmassy the chestnuts the
mushrooms and that nice crisp pastry on
the outside
look at it
i'm ready to die and go to heaven
[Applause]
for a really special occasion i love to
serve my beef wellington with gloriously
creamy mashed potatoes and shavings of
exquisite white truffle
[Music]
my first job on christmas day morning is
to tackle the turkey
and my favorite way to cook it is
roasted with lemon parsley and garlic
it's fantastically aromatic really easy
to do keeps the meat succulent and
tastes absolutely delicious
for me without question the start of the
christmas dinner is this a delicious
turkey now once this is in the oven
you're halfway there the secret success
behind a great christmas dinner is
making sure this doesn't turn out dry
and it's all in the preparation now
we're gonna make an amazing butter
and this
is sort of the start of the the most
important part keeping that bird
incredibly moist soft butter
a touch of salt and pepper
a little touch of olive oil in there
that stops the butter from burning
next add the zest of two lemons
and their juice
this gives the flavored butter a
wonderful citrus zing
three cloves of garlic
turkey's a very delicate dainty meat and
that's why i want the garlic pureed so
it sort of disintegrates
and flavors a turkey
gently without becoming too overpowering
then add a generous handful of chopped
parsley
wow that smells incredibly light give
that a good mix
turkey's a very very very lean bird and
it dries out
so it's so important
to make sure that we help it to cook
perfectly
butter done now prepare the turkey we'll
season the bird
inside the cavity
salt and pepper
next half two onions and pop them in
as they roast they steam inside the bird
giving a lovely sweetness
put in the lemon and a couple of bay
leaves for their bitter sweet spicy
flavor
we're sort of lining the inside of the
turkey with these fantastic
sort of flavours you can see the bird is
upright and it's looking sort of like
it's standing to attention now it's time
to add the flavoured butter just very
very carefully
open up the skin
go through
over the back of the breast
and keep the skin intact
the idea is to gently loosen the skin
with your fingers so the butter can be
stuck underneath it
now once you've loosened all the skin
off the top of the thighs turn the bird
around
and just go through here again hand up
and just release
a little bit but don't completely break
it because i don't want all that butter
to run out
right
from there
now take your butter
put it into a ball
that smells amazing
lemony
citrusy and just
sort of flatten it and stick that in
there
underneath
one side now once you've got it in there
pull back the skin
and just
use that
to sort of slide all the way down
what we want to do now is line the top
of the breast with all that butter there
that butter is going to keep the turkey
breast really seriously moist
turn the bird round
and finish covering the breast with the
butter
turkeys originally came from north
america and they're best young and plump
my favorite breed for christmas is
either north of black or norfolk bronze
both of which have a wonderful gamey
taste
take the rest of the butter and
carefully massage over the breast legs
and wings
you can do all this the night before and
simply cover the turkey with tinfoil and
keep it in the fridge ready to be cooked
on christmas day
into the tray
a little touch
of olive oil now olive oil on top again
that protects it gets that skin really
nice and crispy and it stops the butter
from burning
now in the oven at 220 for 10 minutes to
get really nice and brown
quickly
in she goes
beautiful
[Music]
that smells fantastic
after 10 minutes take the turkey out of
the oven and baste then cover the
breasts with smoked streaky bacon
what i want to do
is add a little bit more flavor i'm
already starting to think
about my gravy
so the bacon protects it stops it from
drying out
but it's going to start
to really give
my gravy a wonderful base
turn down the oven to 180 degrees
this five kilogram bird will feed eight
people comfortably it needs roasting for
two and a half hours or half an hour per
kilo basting every so often
[Music]
back in
and now
she's on the way look at that beautiful
it's as pretty as the christmas tree
that smells
fantastic
wow
look at that
beautiful
that
is 90 of your work done there
to test the turkey is cooked stick a
knife into the bottom of the thigh and
if the juices run clear it's done the
secret now is to let the turkey rest
uncovered for two and a half hours as
the meat relaxes it reabsorbs its juices
making it succulent and tender plus
it'll be easier to carve
it might seem like a long time to let it
rest but remember the turkey doesn't
need to be piping hot because i'm
serving it with hot gravy
that
looks like a million dollars
let that rest
because the flavor will be ten times
more exciting once it's rested
the key to pulling all the different
elements of your christmas dinner
together on the plate is the gravy
my recipe for turkey gravy made with
cider and walnuts has a wonderful aptly
nutty flavor which beautifully
complements the turkey meat and fruity
pork stuffing
as that turkey's resting
i want to make the most amazing gravy
when i say amazing i really do mean
amazing
drain the excess fat from the roasting
tray and put it back on the heat
then remove the bacon from the top of
the turkey
and the roasted onions from the cavity
look at them
my god they smell amazing
finally take out the roasted lemon
first of all cut up the bacon
lovely
bacon into the tray
hear how crispy that is
that's the start
of our gravy
the onion look at it beautiful
doesn't get any better than that chop
that up
onion
and bacon in
that
smells
incredible
when i first got the chance to cook
christmas lunch for the chefs in paris
they taught me one crucial thing
i was only 21 at the time
and they made me rest the turkey for as
long as i cooked it
so i cooked it for three hours and i
rested it for three hours
what a difference
incredible
next chop up the roasted lemon and add
to the tray
put in a couple of sprigs of rosemary to
give it a lovely aromatic punch and fry
then add three chopped tomatoes which
helps to thicken the gravy and give it a
lovely fresh taste
[Music]
now it's time to really get the turkey
flavor into the gravy snap off
the wing
take off all your little trimmings put
these little bits here
add that into your crayfish
these are the bits we never use everyone
throws them away
off
there that little baby there
take him off
i want that
bang flavor delicious try that off
it smells incredible
next pour in the dry cider this adds a
lovely subtle apple flavor that really
lifts the taste of the turkey meat
as the cider starts to reduce pour in
the delicious resting juices from the
roasted turkey
wow there you go
the most amazing flavor
[Music]
when the liquid has reduced by half
crush the vegetables and the turkey
pieces with a masher to extract the
maximum amount of flavor
and basically what's happening now is
that we're giving the gravy a little bit
of body
pour in the chicken stock and reduce
again
in
now a little taste
wow i mean you just close your eyes wow
it oozes flavor and turkey now sieve it
use the back of the ladle to push it
through the sieve extracting every last
drop of flavour
pop in a sprig of rosemary and leave to
infuse ready for the finishing touch
[Music]
simply add crushed walnuts to the bottom
of the gravy boat and ladle in the hot
gravy
[Music]
you